there's been 20 000 sometimes 30 000 in
a month that go through the rgb sector
um and in some cases they get more than
the fat so but
again you're looking at influxes we've
seen this before not to the extent of
this year though it's just it's been
incredible as far as the numbers it's
just
way too many
and uh
where we have this catch and release
policy right now that that's not
beneficial to our country
[Music]
rio grande city along with the entire
rio grande valley has endured
these ties again our broken immigration
system for decades this is a large
influx and in fact it is going to be one
of the it is going to be the highest or
historical high it's going to be the
highest in the in the history of
tracking this and what i understand is
going to be 2.1 historical higher 2.2 so
yes we're going to have the highest
number of apprehensions here in the u.s
mexico border and by the way
border communities are in favor of
securing the border the question is
simply how so you have the issue of
immigration and then you have the issue
of border security but here's the thing
these are not mutually exclusive
concepts they can co-exist the problem
though is we haven't found the middle
ground to make sure that we manage both
because
we are a country of immigrants of the
people by the people and for the people
however we need to handle immigration in
a way that benefits america you cannot
have one state
or a few municipalities deal with the
brunt of this immigration we have to
find a plan a national plan so maybe
incentivize states incentivize
municipalities to take on this law do
the president call the governor sit down
and have a conversation now is that
being naive or not i don't know the
point is that we truly want to address
it they need to sit down and have a
conversation and
if they're not then we're going to
continue to have this this uh divide
about immigration and border security
and my take is it can be solved
[Music]